j'ai réussi ce que j'ai souhaité depuis
le début parce que 95 on va poser la
question justement qu'est ce que je
souhaitais pour les
les cantiques de noël et je disais que
moi ce que j'espère c'est que le
martiniquais se réapproprie de chanter
noël et que ça dans toutes les communes
de toutes les villes on commence à
chanter des cantiques de l'ocs je disais
que 95 n'avons eu leur premier cd et
l'année d'après on a vu arriver à 96
maringouins et l'année d'après pas
besoin de cette ferraille et de qu il ya
eu 2012 groupe à niveau de rêve une date
nous avons un groupe ravit la genoa et
londres est en train de monter justement
un petit groupe de l'illinois c'est pour
nous assurer de la tradition sera bien
sauvegarder et pour parler d'eux
la france hexagonale au jour
d'aujourd'hui il ya au moins une
vingtaine de groupes de cantiques
en france qui se sont formés à face
d'ailleurs je dois partir
le week-end du 8 au 9 pourra les
assassins chantait avec un groupe qui
existe déjà sur la france
[Musique]
m
aujourd'hui ravintsara plus de 30 ans je
dirais d'ailleurs
ça fait deux ans qu'on a fêté les
cantons ne vaut pas ville plate donc
nous avons jeudi
plus de vingt ans de discographie
puisque le premier cd ont la peau dure 4
donc c'était le bois du cours du groupe
par une panne
ensuite il ya eu au moins une dizaine de
plus
triple à au développement justement de
la reprise parce que les cantiques de
noël ça existe depuis 90 ans chez nous
maintenant
la ville a fait sa part de travail
il ya eu aussi manuel qui a fait un gros
travail là dessus et raffinent pas
d'avoir pris le flambeau et sa banlieue